here's something I wasn't even aware you
wrote the movie CIA Central Intelligence
Central Intelligence I did and and you
wrote that for Dwayne The Rock Johnson
you know and Kevin Hart yeah the [__]
movie made you wrote the movie and it
made 216 million dollars did really well
yeah like are you like a super uh
successful writer no I mean I mean we're
working you know like we're definitely
working I mean in all fairness like we
wrote that movie like in 2009 who's we
uh my partner Dave status did you write
the movie with Dwayne The Rock Johnson
in mind like no how are you no no movie
about Central Intelligence it was a
movie kind of based on our high school
experience with a guy we knew and we
wrote it at the time for Ed Helms right
and uh I think like Danny McBride right
it was just one of those scripts where
people would jump on and off like I mean
it was like Will Ferrell and Zach
Galifianakis and then it's John Hammond
will fit do you get excited each time oh
God hey we got Zach Galifianakis I
bought a bottle of champagne one time
and I ordered all this fancy dinner for
my wife because I was like we um making
a movie in Hollywood and then like the
next day if a whole bunch of actors pass
on it then they can just end up saying
hey the script must suck oh yeah
everyone's passed on it but I think the
script was good enough and the idea was
good enough that they kept finding new
teams to come aboard but then Dwayne
gets involved the movie becomes very
real and then once Kevin Hart becomes
involved but it was so great man you
must have been like [__] opening the
champagne windows we were very excited
but then we went to the um press junket
yeah and it's crazy you learn how little
they give a [__] about the writer at
these things like you you conceived this
whole movie I know and they don't they
don't get and I get it like it's all
these like foreign reporters you know
and they're so excited about the rocket
yeah but I don't understand why the
rider it doesn't really like the writers
the whole deal not only did the
reporters not care Dwayne and Kevin
didn't even know who I think they
thought we were like on their team yeah
yeah like at one point you were the
publicist yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
at one point like first of all those
guys like they just talk about each
other like they love each other they're
doing
they invited me but I was doing Mindy at
the time no I was doing uh I was doing
some movie the time so I couldn't go but
they're there and the reporters like
what was it like working with uh Dwayne
The Rock Johnson and Kevin Hart's like
that man is global this man he's a brand
and what I learned and then Dwayne
starts talking about Kevin he's like
this man has a work ethic unlike
anything I've ever seen in my life I
learned from him every day and then as a
joke I'm kind of like what do you guys
think of Dave my co-writer my partner
and Kevin Hart goes who the [__] is Dave
I don't know any [__] Dave
oh